yeah welcome to this video playing clunk
from Qatar I play this modern defense
let's see hmm so something else besides
transposing into pelts with 96 maybe can
play something like that would be five
okay let's grab this temple
so yeah how to how to play no baby maybe
I need to do that and nine f6 mmm a half
interesting i was a bit surprising see
for that he that he closes this actually
okay let's check Knight f6 I'm a bit
worried that he's going to play five I
would have night Eve no I don't have 94
I have 94 I don't have it great analysis
here um II 594 Queens to us it's
nonsense and if id plain' ID for he's
going to play a success is the problem
okay let's do that him it's also not bad
put any to put something in the center
if he place a d5 my idea was to play C 5
i'm only a bit worried that my
development is too slow this is Sir may
be possible yeah yeah something like
that som some very direct move might
blow me out of the water hmm I take on
do and I don't I don't get it though we
take here is this so terrible oh come on
I probably need to do it anyway okay and
then I grew up here this is is so bad
where do you go to be five no I can also
take with them with a night but you just
got this is slightly awkward check yeah
come on let's take with this with this
pawn why is it so what does the exact
problem I mean I understand that I'm
full of witnesses but is it terrible
my queen a farm could be an idea yeah
this just just when you play it your
your your you recognize okay but it's
not that it's not a big issue let's
let's get the King out of them 97 I
probably haven't looked like night age 5
or I'll just Roxy 897 it's not not the
problem oh this is very aggressive
yup he threatening on age 67 this is
some okay inside no use if you place
tonight if he does this i have c forms
but my idea oh whoa whoa i cannot place
Evil Queen h6e for Bishop c4 the
threatening Queen g6 mm all right all
right let's see what is going to play me
yeah I'm really confused in this game
not playing with a consistent player
that's not a good sign maybe move maybe
night g5 imac g4 is in bed and 95 yeah
like that it's not bad at all
yeah maybe i can i can tidy up my
position a bit this is activating and
I'm threatening c6 catching the night
the night doesn't have a square this is
this is probably not so bad this is
better also brooke d 8 coming so look
the eight and c6 how do you how do you
keep your night or is there some better
move even like c4 be three but this
isn't bad this isn't that cannot be
better
mmm yeah maybe I know c66 was worse this
is this is ok it's ok no see sexy the
knowledge is really a good piece now I
can go to a seven but this is really
hard to believe um just the rope here
just the route and take it
yeah this was a very shaky position
somewhere right right in the opening
okay it's the modern defense what do you
expect it's a violating one or two one
or two just principles okay I should
should keep it closed yeah but ops ii
eight would be nice yeah I can we can
put that
hmm no i didn't i didn't really have
didn't really see that he can take it I
thought I have 93 with a fork but this
is of course complete nonsense okay but
I'm trying for counter tech has not two
not bad at all I hope it takes i have
this check on a three and this looks
this is dangerous not only looks
dangerous i think it is a dangerous okay
the check check check check yeah King f2
Quincy five is like resign is almost
made I did two or something yeah i was i
was in very the very shaky stadium this
looks it looks dangerous at least i'm
not sure if it is this really bad i mean
sometimes you were you are surprised
what Todd sorts what's playable it
doesn't seem to be a winning for white
and this is actually leading to two
black edge rock the a dispatcher even
but yeah the comp comp oh all the way
likes my position it's really strange I
mean unexpected he had wants to take on
c7 and this is probably good Queen c7m
you need to get the square d 6 for the
night it's not the pole it's a square
and the way it was played this night was
was just just getting trapped yeah he
needed 2 he needed to take badly on c7
here here Queens the seven what was good
alright thanks for watching